và báo tên times, tổng thủ Mỹ đường nân tròm đang sân sẽ át thử nhất cầu nắm chăm phần chăm,
đối với dầu mỏ của ngà, nhắm cả vào các đối tác thủ mại khác.
Đấy đều có là phản nứng cướng giám chương viện ngà cái tục tự trối đàn phản hoa bình,
và ra thăng tình công tại UQNH.
Truyên giám, mà xin mi lên hết tại vì những nghiên cứu chính xích đúng ngoại trâu dân.
Mất tuyên này tương đương lệnh cấm phận toàn cầu, đối với dầu ngà,
sau bài tổng hoa nghi, liệu tổng thương trân có giám chăm nhận dủ sau,
giá rầu dột một chăm đối là Mỹ một thủ hệ không.
Châu khi đó, một số lị sĩ Mỹ đang muốn hạnh chế quyền của tổng thống trong bởi này.
Phần nứng chưa đồng thái trên, thứ trường ngoại gong ngà sẽ gây viễn có tình mũ,
mắt sửa thích nghi và không thầy đổi đường lối chục quyền.
Ông khẩn định hơn bà mình yên biển phát trường phát tự đường áp lên ngà,
cho thấy khả năng chống chiều của nền kinh tế này.
Ngòi trường phát tự người tám của ai ui hệ bị đình trẻ vì bất đồng người bầu.
Chúng khi Mỹ có giống hiểu nối lại viện trở quân sự chỗ khỏe nè.
Thích bản đối theo kinh tế tổng cầu đang hình sống, bối sống mò, là định nắm tiếp theo.